this video was made possible by the
lovely people supporting me on patreon
hello if you've not seen one of my
videos before my name's simon i make
science videos and i just wrote my first
book if you have watched some of my
videos before then hello my name's simon
i make science videos and i just wrote
my first book it's an introduction to
and history of atmospheric science
called firmament the hidden science of
weather climate change in the air that
surrounds us available to pre-order
right now at the link down there in the
description in this video i want to
answer some questions that i've been
asked elsewhere about how and why i
wrote the book starting with how did i
get the opportunity to write a book in
the first place the answer to that
question is actually quite simple i got
an email from a publisher called hodder
and stokes and asking me if i would be
interested in writing a book and that
was something that i had anticipated
being asked in fact it's something i
kind of
engineered long-term viewers of the
channel will know that i've released a
bunch of videos about books some like
favorite textbooks or a book club or
whatever the reason i started making
those videos was because i've been a
lifelong book nerd and i've always
wanted to be an author and i figured
that a reasonably successful youtube
channel would be a good way to
springboard into writing a book and that
series was basically a multi-year play
to try and attract the attention of
book publishers and book editors and
that plan unbelievably actually seemed
to work so after receiving that email i
went to hodder and stoughton and had a
meeting where i pitched a couple of
different ideas for books that i had one
of which was firmament and they really
liked that idea and said right okay
great go away and write us a book
proposal a book proposal is a relatively
long document that formerly pitches a
book so within there there's a form that
basically asks you to fill out who you
are why we should trust you to write a
book you know what do you know about
this subject but also things like who is
the book going to appeal to and a rough
skeleton structure of what's actually
going to go in there so chat to my
chapter what you think is going to go
into the book and attached to that is a
sample of your writing so a couple of
thousand words that i think quite
frequently actually becomes part of the
introduction to the book um that
basically gives the publisher a chance
to see what your authorial voice is like
and if you're pants at writing or not
now at this point in my life when i was
asked to provide several thousand words
of a writing sample i thought i had a
pretty good idea of how i wrote because
i've written a lot over the course of my
life i wrote short stories when i was a
kid i wrote like 70 000 words of a novel
when i was a teenager and just deleted
it because i wasn't happy and then more
recently i wrote an entire phd thesis i
thought that it would be easy just to
kind of put put a bunch of words down on
the page but it turns out that that
academic writing style that i got which
is very specific to academia from from
the phd
didn't really sit with a lot of my other
writing experience particularly actually
writing for youtube when i make science
videos i normally script them word for
word and um it took a little while to
kind of combine the two into what i felt
like was the
the popular science writing version of
me and it's i guess somewhere between
those two polls of youtube and academia
what's interesting isn't that now
looking back on that writing sample it
it's very obvious to me that it was two
versions of me that were pulling in
opposite directions as the book went on
and i wrote i don't even know how many
thousands of words have been written in
total and then you know subsequently
deleted uh i feel like i found a much
more authentic version of that voice and
i feel like it's a lot more convincing
to me now
whether that's convincing to other
people still remains to be seen the book
hasn't actually been released yet what
mattered of course was that the
publisher liked the writing sample and
they sent over a contract for me to sign
and there were a couple of extra steps
here where i got a literary agent and
they renegotiated the contract and blah
blah blah blah blah but anyway i signed
a contract in i think august 2019 to
provide the book by
mid-2020 and from there i went into
research mode because
i obviously
i did a phd in atmospheric science i
know a lot about this field and i had a
skeleton structure of what i wanted to
go into the book but the process of
writing was largely a process of
researching because
there's all manner of different things
that need to go into the book that i
haven't learned as part of formal
education whether that's extra levels of
complexity that i just want to
understand before i try and explain a
concept more broadly or if it's little
factoids and bits of information like
the the illegality of weather
forecasting in england in the 19th
century for example for each topic that
i knew i'd be doing more research on i
compiled a list of good sources and
tracked them down basically most of them
are online some of them are actually in
physical places like my local library in
one or two cases several were in the
british library which i got to go and do
some research in i actually vlogged this
because i thought this experience would
be something that i could vlog and i'd
go to interesting places and meet
interesting people and
we got a pandemic instead longtime
viewers of the channel will not be at
all surprised to learn that i made a
notion database for this project and
each one of those sources got its own
page where i could take notes and each
chapter in the book had its own page in
another database where i could you know
pile in the information and compile it
and then reorder it so that i could
basically follow a basic story telling
structure which is what i do for all my
videos at some point i will do a video
on how i approach science communication
and how i think it transcends different
formats but basically i wanted to try
and tell a story within each chapter and
i followed a bullet point structure and
then brought in information from those
sources as and when it was needed for
the first real chapter in the initial
structure i actually compiled all the
information first and then wrote the
whole thing and that took way too long
and for all the following chapters i
basically sketched out the rough
structure filled in some detail and then
wrote through and as i needed to get
more information i would look it up and
then quite frequently you get to the end
and actually find that oh well this
structure doesn't work and you reorder
things around but we'll get to that
stage later all this is to say i did a
bunch of research came up with a
structure and then opened a word
document and started writing i actually
filmed that moment
right i'll see you in like 80 000 words
for those of you wondering why i didn't
use latex and i used word instead one
that's because i don't need to typeset
the book i don't need to make it look
nice i just need to provide the text and
two because i think if i used latex i
would be very tempted to include lots
and lots of equations because that's
just what i do in latex and that's not
what you do in popular science writing
so basically starting in late 2019 and
for pretty much all of 2020 i was
researching and writing the book and
this was of course somewhat uh
messed with by the pandemic partly
because originally i was going to go to
lots of places and research facilities
and archives and uh make vlogs of the
experience but also put myself a bit
more into the book and have a bit more
kind of the personal experience of you
know going into somewhere and you can
smell the the ancient pages and you know
just provide that bit of personal flavor
i guess to the text obviously that
didn't happen but also the book was
delayed because i got covered and that
completely threw out the initial plan of
submitting the initial manuscript in
june 2020 we actually had to push the uh
kind of deadline day to december 2020.
so for the entire pandemic year i was
alongside doing videos and streams and
everything like that
researching and writing the book and
just kind of gradually week by week
getting to the final goal of this
complete manuscript originally i used to
put in my daily routine that i would
write for an hour and what i found was
it was very possible to
write for an hour and not produce any
words at all because you just kind of be
researching a bit and then writing a
beer and then researching and being oh
no i actually don't feel this and then
delete it and you end up exactly where
you started the following day what i
found was a much more effective goal was
to write a hundred words that was my
goal for five days a week was to write
100 words because
writing 100 words is actually very easy
it doesn't take long at all depending on
what you're writing about but once
you've written them you think well okay
i've already kind of set up i've got a
drink i've got everything open i need
open i'm just going to keep going and
quite frequently you'd write 500 or a
thousand words in a day and eventually i
upped the goal it wasn't 100 words in a
day it was 500 words in a day and i
think in the last month and just a
semi-mad rush for the finish line i
think i had a thousand words today um
and
i i hit it you know when it becomes a
regular goal a regular part of your
routine it just it's a thing that you do
and
i did it all this is to say i submitted
a complete manuscript i think actually
about a week or two early at the end of
2020 and then i had a couple of weeks
off from the project and then the edits
began in my mind at least the editing
process takes place in three stages the
first of which is asking basically are
the chapters in the right order and the
way that we approached this was i bullet
pointed the kind of key messages of each
chapter in the book and then said right
you know do these make sense are we you
know loading the front half of the book
or the back half of the book or is it
evenly spread and what we actually found
was that the start of the book and the
end of the book were fine but the middle
was a bit muddled and we actually added
i think two chapters to make the
information a bit more palatable and to
not make it read like a textbook because
there was one chapter in particular that
was very much just like reading a
textbook and
wasn't the state of goal the second
stage is then going into each chapter
and asking are the paragraphs in the
right order are the concepts you're
introducing taking place in a sensible
way can we colony concepts do we need to
add any others do we need to change any
analogies and this process is the part
that takes the longest time um some
chapters actually didn't take very long
at all uh my editor ian just sent over
basically one round of notes for some
chapters and it was like okay cool yeah
i'll just you know move this paragraph
here just cut out that sentence add a
sentence here rubber stamp great that
one is now ready to go down the line
other chapters however such as the ones
in the middle were a lot more work
sometimes there were three or four
iterations to get them right so i would
send something to ian he would write up
notes on it send them over to me we'd
then have a video call to talk it
through i'd implement the notes with my
own kind of suggestions on top send it
back and then
repeat the process and eventually those
chapters were hammered out those ones in
the middle of the book to me are i think
some of the best chapters because
they've
been through the forge so many times
i've really hit them with a hammer and i
think got them to the right form now
hopefully right now as of the time of
releasing this video we have just
finished this second stage of editing
which may seem a little premature but
actually the third stage of editing is
going through line by line and asking is
the grammar correct is the spelling
correct that kind of stuff which
actually i don't do and my editor
doesn't do that gets sent off to a copy
editor who then returns the manuscript
with any
mistakes corrected potentially with you
know a couple of notes asking did you
mean this in which case you need to
change it to this that kind of thing but
that is hopefully going to be quite a
quick process once these three stages of
editing are done
that's pretty much the point at which my
hands are off the wheel like there is
one other step when they send over the
page proofs that i can check to see if
i'm happy with the way it looks on the
page
but at this point the book is written
and
i i've just got to kind of let my baby
go off into the world and
eventually see it in shops in a couple
of months rising this book was a long
process in fact it's almost exactly
three years from the day i received that
first email to the day that i will see
it in bookshops so it's taking a long
time and it has been difficult it's a
process that is it's difficult holding
all the information in your head about
the book whilst you're trying to edit it
but also whilst you're writing it you
necessarily only write about a fraction
of what you research you only
cherry-pick the most relevant the most
interesting bits and you have to
summarize down these large concepts into
digestible
sentences and that's a tough process
like
it was harder than i thought it would be
but it is a process that i enjoyed i
enjoy writing i enjoy researching and
writing the book has made me
so much better as a writer i feel like i
found my voice a lot more i look back on
the stuff that i wrote two a bit years
ago now and it's it's like a totally
different person wrote it um somebody
who was just clunky
and was like tripping over their own
feet trying to write something that
sounded right i feel just so much more
comfortable in the process now if i had
the opportunity to do this again in the
future i probably take it
but let's focus on getting this one
finished shall we but anyway that's how
i wrote my first book i hope that this
was at least interesting you know
looking behind the curtain a little bit
and potentially even useful if you
yourself might like to write a piece of
non-fiction in the future if you still
have any questions about the book or
about how i wrote it then i'll be
chilling out down there in the comments
for an hour or two after this video is
released now remember that supporters on
patreon get the most direct access to
ask me questions at any time in the
comments or in messages because it's the
least i can do for the people that
directly financially support this
channel thank you guys you're awesome
here's some recommended viewing next if
you enjoyed the video then please do pop
it a like and that just leaves me to say
thanks for watching i'll see in the next
one